so what we're gonna do my friends is
write a joke using the word of the day
which is primary let's try to see if we
can get that from
bouncing
today we are using the pilot
G2 blue
we are doing the pilot G2 blue
so let's get into it my friends
welcome
to the right Tang Club so we have 10
minutes on the clock
the name of the game is to write a new
joke
in 10 minutes
based on a single word today's word is
primary
today's date is
eight nine
today's the ninth right
so for the next 10 minutes
all we are focusing on
is writing a joke using the word primary
good morning Aaron despiva he said good
morning right Tenors good to see you fam
what goody what's goody to all my right
Tenors out there
and for the next 10 minutes
let us write
three two one
start the clock
primary okay so primary I always start
with what I think of what do I associate
when I hear the word primary so
let me try to move this camera over I'm
gonna be leaning forward oh that's great
I guess I won't be leaning forward all
right let's try to write like this
um so primary what comes to mind is
first comes to mind is elections
this comes to mind as voting
you can also think of common phrases
common words
um makes you think of things in the
Zeitgeist makes you think some cultural
norms or not Norms just whatever comes
to mind with the word primary list it
out
spit it out
um a common phrase primary reason
primary candidate and as you are
brainstorming you can also think of what
is the opposite as well so like primary
means first okay so maybe right last
first and last Also may make you think
of
you know
gold medal
um participation trophy maybe something
there
uh looks like Lance said Primary School
there we go I think is that um is that
like Elementary School
I believe
um I just look like a youth pastor I'm
not so I'm not hip to all the the kid
terms
um
Primary School
primary colors says Juan there we go
el primero colores
Los primero colores
uh foreign
[Music]
Spanish I learned in a kitchen so
those are the kind of words that I know
um Prime ribs yep primary ribs perhaps
cool we're getting a lot of good things
out
um
I was thinking of um
uh La Mota is uh muchos
[Music]
he uh
como se dice purple
you don't know say
Gasolina all right anyway let's let's
focus here my 80d just went on
a run there so primary elections voting
first last
gold medal for top um participation
trophy prime interest rates I'm really
trying to stick to
the actual word
and I know it can be flexible with how
you want to write it but I like to stick
to the word as specifically as possible
primary caregiver
okay okay Jesse
uh Dean said primary teeth
very nice
caregiver
so maybe with primary caregiver maybe
there's a joke around
being the oldest or being the only child
um
makes you
gold medal participation trophy I'm just
trying to think of like primary
a joke using primary school could be
something about
flunking out of college
I mean like relax that was just my
primary school
um and it could be like your reach
School
um so as we're getting to five minutes I
usually like to brainstorm the first
five minutes
and then
um
construct the joke in the second
so do you all have something
that sticks out here
Bob Kirk said primary lover oh my
Heavens so
primary reason primary candidate
Primary School primary color
that would be white
um isn't like first you know there could
be a joke on like the white devil there
perhaps you know there could be
something interesting there
um
Premier ribs primary teeth
vote in the primaries so now we're
trying to
primary
reason
so it could be
my mission
is to inspire
people
to vote
that's
my
primary
reason
for living okay so I mean we're just
getting the ideas out here we're just
finding connections we're just seeing
what we can make stick here
my mission is to inspire people to vote
that's my primary reason for living
um
oh Prime Amazon Prime Amazon primary
and there could be voting you could vote
there is a in joke writing of like
trying to remix two words so it could be
like inspiring people to vote it could
be voting for an election but you could
remix that into voting on America's Got
Talent
um
voting
on like a buzzfeed article
um primary contact is another good word
there Caleb I like that
so in the last three minutes here let's
start to really Whittle this down I
haven't really honed in on a specific
idea or joke I'm trying to construct I
kind of played around with my mission is
to inspire people to vote
that's my primary reason for living I
think if we were to do that it would
need to end on primary reason
because you always want to end your
jokes on the punch line on the punch
word I think I've mistake a lot of young
Comics make is that they try they say
the punchline and then keep talking you
want to end on that word so how could we
end
with primary reason or primary vote
um
so I you know
my wife it could be something like my
wife asked me
we should vote early
in the primaries or like
what's your primary reason for living
it could be like to avoid voting
um exercising my right not to vote
is one
but my wife and I voted early
there could be a race joke there if um
if like everyone on the ballot was white
maybe that's like a primary color thing
um
primary teeth primary color Primary
School
primary candidate primary reason
oh the primary voting was done in the
primary school yeah I like that Caleb so
in the final minute here let's try to
whittle something together here
so my mission inspired people to vote
that's my primary reason for living I
don't hate that I think we just need to
misdirect it a little bit more
foreign I tell everyone to vote
oh it could be I don't understand people
that don't vote it's our primary reason
for living
that's still not ending on primary
reason
so
how could we end on it people don't vote
as speaking of ending
we have arrived
so I don't get people that don't vote
primary reason
I don't get why people don't vote
[Music]
um
I don't get why people don't vote cool
well the closest thing we got was my
mission is to inspire people to vote
that's my primary reason for living
so
a few things I didn't do here and is a
big reason why we didn't really get
to a specific ending one thing or a
specific like a a joke
specifically one thing
um at the end of the day
the more you write like the more chances
you give yourself to write a joke you
know and all the interviews I've done
people say you write 20 jokes and end up
keeping one of them so just
statistically if you sit down to write a
single joke in 10 minutes most likely
you're not going to find something
but it's all about practicing and
exercising that riding muscle now a few
things I could have done
to really move this along and you know
really uh maximize my chances of finding
a good joke
one
um
actually focusing I was kind of all over
the place a little bit so just focusing
on the task at hand two though asking
myself what is the premise of my joke I
never really honed in on
what am I trying to say here I did a
bunch of brainstorming kind of made a
silly connection here
never really was like okay well what is
the premise what am I trying to say here
because if you don't know the premise
the audience isn't going to know the
premise and they're most definitely not
going to know to laugh because there's
not going to be a joke
and then the third thing I could have
done is to think about how to
personalize this
what I did here my mission has inspired
people to vote that's my primary reason
for living I was just trying to think of
a funny word play but I wasn't thinking
of okay how does voting personally
affect me what is my personal opinion on
it was my personal experience with this
topic
also didn't look at the other options I
just kind of ran with primary reason and
thought I could Whittle some sort of
word play out of it without thinking of
the premise or how I could personalize
it
so that's really what happened here
is I essentially just didn't even I did
a little brainstorming and then just
kind of thought I would magically you
know Whittle it together but at the end
of the day
your sense of humor is nearly yours and
people say you can't teach funny but you
can teach people how to write funny
which then translates them into being
funny so I do think you can't teach
funny but I do think there is an
instinct and a timing to it just like
with people learning to play guitar not
everyone's Jimi Hendrix but people can
learn how to you know play the guitar
it's just your competent level
depends on some of your natural ability
and also the amount of work you're
willing to put into it
so for this joke I just skipped a few of
the
the common things I usually do uh mainly
because I'm a little over caffeinated
perhaps
so
but that's just exercise we do this
every single Wednesday at 10 A.M it's a
live stream on this YouTube channel
so um come on back check out the other
videos we've done as well I have other
examples of when I do do this exercise
do too
angels
and um
have a good day out there
cool